[Music]
your family must be so proud of you now
though yes even though they laughed me
they are still very proud of me and
there they do they watch your show did
you really do all your relatives watch
the show sometimes it can get a little
risque it can yeah my all my relatives
watch it they're all proud even my
grandparents I have very Catholic
grandparents they watch it they love it
my my boyfriend actually watched it with
my grandpa and his best friend who's 75
in a hunting camp up in upstate New York
and he said every time we said the word
I'm allowed to say I'm here
say what vagina just say Vegeta yeah
every time I said that word on the
episode of the show yeah the show or me
or kat dennings my love the amazing
co-star he said you could see my
grandpa's knuckles just getting wider
and wider as he was gripping gripping
his seat watch it I'll tell you
something and I know this from
experiences they come from very uptight
Catholic people you can do horrific
horrible things on a TV show they wipe
it clean from their mind the minute it's
over
they know that even forgiven they just
wiped it clean
I'll see my parents after we do a risque
thinking here on the show and they'll
say how we love that show what part did
you like and they'll say we like this
this this and then there's the part
where like I don't know dildos fell from
the ceiling
they don't mention that part that's not
happening tonight that's tomorrow
night's show
[Laughter]
what's wrong with you / what is wrong
with you people
swear to God I probably gonna be there
on dildo night show over there this show
if you're watching it now it's
impossible it's not airing